bonjour bienvenue au Parlement européen
pour un nouveau numéro d'Europe Hebdo et
l'actualité de la semaine c'est bien
évidemment cette mer Méditerranée cette
marineostrom qui devient de plus en plus
un cercueil pour les migrants face à la
tragédie l'Europe convoque un sommet
extraordinaire urgence oblige en 2015 un
migrant meurt toutes les 2 heures en
Méditerranée regardez le
reportage impressionnante opération de
secours au large de la Grèce cette fois
mais pas
seulement les informations se suivent et
ressemble des centaines de migrants
perdition au large de la Libye un appel
au secours le drame de ces naufragés à
répétition est bien réelle celui survenu
dans la nuit de samedi 18 au dimanche 19
avril a choqué par son ampleur 800 morts
selon le HCR des hommes des femmes et
enfants qui périssent
noyés la semaine dernière il y a eu deux
des plus graves naufrages qu'on n jamais
connu 100 personnes sont mortes et les
survivants sont arrivés à Rio de Calabre
mardi matin et hier nous avons appris la
nouvelle des 700 des chiffres qui font
froid dans le dos 35000 migrants sont
arrivés par bateau dans le sud de
l'Europe depuis le début de l'année et
1600 sont portés
disparu le problème ici ce n'est pas le
nombre de réfugiés qui arrivve par la
mer l'année dernière entre janvier et
avril 26600 migrants sont arrivés cette
année ils étaient 22000 MIG environ donc
le flux migratoire est resté le même ce
qui change c'est le nombre de morts
l'année dernière à la même époque il y
en avait 96 aujourd'hui il y en a 1600
c'est ça la grande différence les
candidats à l'exil viennent
essentiellement de Libye de Syrie ou
d'éritrée des pays en guerre où la
situation politique est loin d'être
stabilisée c'est un véritable enfer
partout en Libye à partir du moment où
tu es un étranger le fait que tu sois
blanc ou noir n'a pas d'importance tu
n'es pas un citoyen tu es en
enfer l'Union européenne est prête à
réexaminer la répartition des demandeurs
d'asile au sein des 28 et plus seulement
au sein des pays du sud de l'Europe
l'Europe qui mise aussi sur la formation
d'un gouvernement stable en libyie
principale porte de sortie vers
l'eldorado
européen alors nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau Jean artui bonjour vous êtes
député européen président de la
commission des budgets ici au Parlement
européen d'abord une réaction à la vue
de ces images de ces migrants qu'
tentent de secourir depuis les côtes
grecques ou même italiennes ce sont des
tragédies qui se
multiplient des hommes des femmes des
familles des enfants qui fuit la misère
qui fuit la guerre l'instabilité autour
du bassin
méditerranéen mais l'Europe est mise en
cause l'opinion publique s'interroge que
fait l'Europe et l'Europe ils ont raison
ceux qui mettent en cause l'Europe je
crois qu'ils ont raison mais ils doivent
mettre en cause la façon dont l'Europe
fonctionne le gouvernement de l'Europe
en fait il y a pas de gouvernement en
Europe et l'image que donne l'Europe
c'est l'image de l'impuissance c'est
l'image pathétique des minutes de
silence nous attendons une puissance
européenne et donc de la part des chefs
d'État et de gouvernement un engagement
plus fort et pourquoi une telle
impuissance on l'a dit les les Dr ch
chef d'État et de gouvernement essaie de
prolonger l'illusion qu'il aurait encore
en main des prérogatives de souveraineté
diplomatique militaire numérique fiscal
énergie il faudrait intégrer tout ça
fédérer tout ça il faut fédérer sinon
nous donnerons l'image d'une Europe
impuissante et et l'Europe deviendra la
cible et
l'argumentaire de tous les populistes
donc il faut en sortir même la
surveillance des frontières fédérer une
naturellement forcément et donner à
Frontex les moyens dont Frontex a besoin
savez-vous par exemple voà vous êtes
spécialist du budget lorsquun oui bien
c'est c'est 120 l'opération Triton là
qui a remplacé 12 millions mais c'est
une infiniment moins qui était
marineostrom auparavant c'est 120
millions par an c'est la moitié du
budget de la Fédération Française de
football c'est un montant dérisoire
Frontex est installé à Varsovie et il
faut savoir que Frontex c'est l'agence
europé de surveillance des frontières
qui surveille qui coordonne mais dont
les pouvoirs sont un millions de budgets
par mois absolument et normalement
lorsquun pay lorsqu'un pays accueille
une agence il signe une convention de
siège pour faciliter les conditions de
vie des collaborateurs qui ne sont pas
euh du du du pays où est cette agence et
bien il faut savoir que depuis 11 ans
qu' existe Frontex la Pologne n'a
toujours pas signé la convention de
siège ce qui complique singulièrement
l'accueil de collaborateurs autres que
polonais à Varsovie donc il faut que
l'Europe bouge incontestablement et il
faudra en tirer les conséquences au plan
budgétaire il faut qu'on a les moyens
est-ce que l'Europe elle a les moyens de
ses ambitions budgétairement
financièrement en périe les états
isolément les états isolément ne peuvent
rien faire et ils n'atteignent
l'effectivité de la souveraineté qu'en
partageant cette souveraineté donc il y
a urgence à faire bouger la façon dont
l'Europe est politiquement pilotée il
faut aller vers ces pays d'où partent
ces bateaux et coopérer avec les
autorités locales lorsqu'il y en a être
présent pour empêcher le départ de ces
bateaux vous avez parlé du d'urgence
justement le chef de l'État François
Hollande en a parlé aussi de cette
urgence je vous propose de l'écouter et
on réagit juste
après si nous ne traitons pas les causes
mêmees de ce qui produit ces drames la
première c'est que il y a un état la
Libye qui n'est plus un état et donc qui
ne contrôle rien voire même qui laisse
faire il y a aussi des pays qui sont à
l'abandon je pense à l'éritrée et avec
des réfugiés qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux je pense a à ce qui se produit
au S la France joue son rôle donc il
nous faut traiter ces causes là et puis
il faut lutter contre le terrorisme
parce qu'il faut savoir que ceux qui
font les trafics qui mettent des
personnes sur des bateaux des bateaux
pourris des vaisseaux qui sont fait pour
disparaître en mer on en sait davantage
maintenant sur ce qui s'est passé sur la
Méditerranée c'està-dire avec un bateau
où hélas les familles étaient enfermé et
ne pouvaient pas sortir et bien ce sont
des terroristes et en luttant contre ces
trafiquants nous lutterons contre le
terrorisme en luttant contre le
terrorisme nous lutterons contre ces
trafiquant parce qu'il se finance sur la
misère du monde il se finance sur la
détresse il se finance sur la
mort jeanu ces filièr d'immigration
clandestine c'est quelque part du du
terrorisme comme le dit le chef de
l'État oui oui et si l'on veut lutter
efficacement contre le terrorisme il
faut qu'il y ait un pilotage politique
un gouvernement ce qui est en cause
c'est la gouvernance de l'Union
européenne j'espère qu'on en tirera les
leçons et qu'on trouvera les moyens de
travailler ensemble plus étroitement et
de mobiliser les moyens nécessaires pour
recréer les conditions de de
fonctionnement normal d'un état dans
tous ces pays qui sont en difficulté
également de mobiliser des moyens
appropriés pour le développement de ces
pays les personnes qui tentent de venir
vers l'Europe sont des personnes qui
fuient à la fois la guerre et la misère
la misère économique h d'accord vous
êtes aussi donc le président de la
commission des budgets hein ici au
Parlement je voulais revenir sur cette
actualité aussi économique avec vous le
plan Junker un plan qui vise à rebooster
l'économie dans l'Union européenne
315 milliards d'euros qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire il y a un vote en
plainère en juin si je ne m'abuse le le
Parlement a été extrêmement pront il
s'est mobilisé largement puisque nous
avons on eu deux commissions qui ont
travaillé conjointement la commission
ECON et la commission des budgets nous y
avons associé deux autres commissions
Tran et itré et nef autres commissions
au total 13 commissions du Parlement
européen ont travaillé ensemble pour
rapidement convenir d'un mécanisme
permettant dès l'été prochain la mise en
œuvre du plan Junker il s'agit de
combler ce déficit d'investissement qui
affecte l'ensemble de l'Union européenne
et en stimulant l'investissement là où
il peut activer l'économie susciter de
relancecherche c'est pas seulement de la
relance c'est vraiment de
l'investissement c'est de
l'investissement d'avenir c'est de la
recherche c'est des réseaux c'est quoi
concrètement alors pour le français qui
nous écoute c'est des c'est des réseaux
de communication ce sont des
laboratoires de recherche qu'on va aider
ce sont des PME auprès desquels la la
BEI va pouvoir intervenir et le Fond
Européen d'Investissement c'est vraiment
une mobilisation générale 315 milliards
pour pour l'investissement pour la
croissance et pour l'emploi c'est sans
précédent nous allons entrer en
conciliation avec le conseil nous sommes
entrés dès ce matin en conciliation avec
le conseil et j'ai bon espoir que le 24
juin prochain le Parlement européen va
pouvoir approuver ce mécanisme
permettant la mise en œuvre la
mobilisation de ces moyens de ces
capitaux privés avec des garanti
consenti par l'Union européenne et par
la Banque européenne d'investissement
c'est je crois un age très fort il faut
que les États-membres également appuient
cette nécessaire confiance pour que
l'Europe reparte de l'avant merci
jeanartu on vous sent passionné sur sur
le sujet merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation tout de suite place au au
magazine les élections législative en
Grande-Bretagne c'est pour bientôt c'est
le 7 mai un thème principal
l'immigration comme vous allez le
constater dans ce reportage de RIM
benhamer
ils sont pompiers musiciens avocats leur
point commun ce sont tous des imigrés
installés en Grande-Bretagne et ils font
partie de la campagne je suis un
immigrant lancé par le mouvement contre
la
xénophobie 15 migrants ont pris la pose
et s'affiche fièrement dans 400 stations
de métro et bus à travers tout le pays
parmi eux Wendy une biologiste
américaine arrivée il y a 9 ans elle
dénonce la montée du
Angleterre les gens disent des choses
horribles des choses très choquantes
comme tous les immigrés devrai être
renvoyés chez
eux mais ici c'est chez moi je n'irai
nulle part ailleurs c'est
éurant pour les associations de défense
des migrants il y a donc urgence à agir
ce projet a vu le jour grâce au
financement participatif en 2 semaines
44000 livres collecté le timing ne doit
rien au hasard la Grande-Bretagne est en
pleine campagne pour les élections
législatives de mai le moment idéal pour
faire passer leur
message nous sommes pas pour l'ouverture
totale des frontières nous sommes un
mouvement responsable mais nous voulons
que les migrants ici soi protégés
respectés et que ce qu'ils apportent au
Royaume-Uni soit
valorisé donc c'est un message pour tous
les partis politiques faites attention
quand vous mentez sur les immigrés
l'immigration est donc plus que jamais
au cœur de la campagne après le succès
du parti anti-européen et
anti-immigration youukip aux dernières
élections européennes toutes les
formations politiques se sont emparé du
sujet pour Peter whitt candidat de
youukip dans cette banlieue du sud de
Londres son parti a simplement libéré la
parole ce n'est pas une campagne
antiimmigré juste que le sujet de
l'immigration en Angleterre a été exclu
du débat
public les gens avaient peur d'en parler
parce qu'ils étaient automatiquement
traités de
racistes est-ce que je peux compter sur
votre soutien c'est sûr je voterai pour
vous leur discours très ferme sur
l'immigration séduit instaurer des
quotas un système migratoire à point et
surtout sortir de l'Europe ils sont
crédités de 15% inention de vote dans
cette circonscription Peter whitt
affronte Spencer Drury le candidat du
Parti conservateur la droite tente de
chasser sur les terres de yukip à leur
tour les conservateurs proposent un
référendum sur l'Europe et durcissent le
ton sur
l'immigration David Cameron veut une
limite plus claire sur le nombre de
personnes qui entrent en Grande-Bretagne
mais nous nous voulons surtout poser des
limites sur le système social quand on
rencontre les électeurs l'une de leurs
principales critiques c'est que les
immigrés viennent réclamer des aides
sociales nous devons être très clair
nous ne permettrons pas aux gens de
profiter du système de ce
pays grande nouveauté de ce scrutin même
les travaillistes font campagne sur ce
thème il propose de renforcer les
contrôles migratoires et de limiter
l'accès aux prestations sociales à 2 ans
pour les migrants Garet Thomas candidat
du leilbour aux élections justifie ce
revirement
nous voulons sévir contre l'immigration
illégale nous voulons un contrôle plus
strict de nos frontières pour lutter
contre les
passeur l'immigration est un vrai sujet
et nous devons avoir un débat politique
sur ce sujet tout en condamnant les
attitudes racistes et
xénophobes ce scrutin est très serré les
conservateurs sont crédités de 30 %
comme les travaillistes aucun N donc de
majorité clair au Parlement et ils
devront former une coalition yukip
pourrait alors rentrer en jeu grâce aux
alliances et pousser le nouveau
gouvernement à durcir sa politique sur
l'immigration voilà un reportage de RIM
benhamer deux députés européens
britanniques nous ont rejoint Jean
Lambert bonjour vous êtes membres du
Green Party he le parti des veres à vos
côté Richard corb du Parti travailliste
bonjour donc on va on va pas refaire la
campagne britannique ici d'abord vous
êtes député européen je voulais vous
poser une question sur ces naufrages en
Méditerranée de ces migrants qui veulent
aller vers l'eldorado européen souvent
britannique une
réaction c'est c'est bien clair que ces
naufrages sont terribles c'est rien de
nouveau moi j'étais à Lampedusa il y a
presque 10 ans maintenant et c'est
toujours la même chose il y a des come
on dit en anglais les larmes de
crocodiles c'est très triste mais on
fait pas grand-chose et je crois qu'on
doit améliorer
le l'aide au Méditerrané mais on doit
donner aussi la possibilité de VI venir
en Europe pour trouver l'asile et ça
c'est c'est h de question en ce moment
Richard c'est évidemment épouvantable
j'espère quand même que ça va réveiller
l'Europe c'est quand même un problème
commun on peut pas dire que c'est un
problème italien ou grec c'est un
problème commun on doit agir ensemble
mais la Grande-Bretagne a un peu réagi à
sa manière quand même à Calais dans le
port de Calais elle a construit un grand
grand grillage en France pour empêcher
les migrants de de passer ça c'est
l'autre question ils sont pas dans des
des des bateaux qui risquent de couler
quand même c'est un problème tout à fait
différent c'est des gens qui sont déjà
entrés dans l'Union européenne il s'agit
de voir dans dans quel quel pays aurait
dû aurait dû procéder à le l'examen
initial de leur demande d'entrée
revenons au sujet qui nous intéresse on
a vu dans le reportage de RIM
Benamer on a interrogé beaucoup
d'immigrés installés près près de
Londres ils disent que l'immigré fait
peur en
Grande-Bretagne est-ce qu'ils ont raison
est-ce qu'il y a du racisme en
Grande-Bretagne
oui c'est clair il y a du racisme en
Grande-Bretagne je crois que ça c'est en
train d'augmenter à cause de le débat
don le C campagne électorale même avant
euh il y a vraiment une quoi une idée
que d'être immigré c'est quelque chose
d'onux on doit pas être ici on cherche à
l'argent sans rien faire et c'est pas la
réalité mais je crois que ça a augmenté
pendant la campagne électorale
oui pas tout le monde heureusement à
cette attitude mais une grande minorité
et UK est très malin il essaie de jouer
sur ça et de lier ça à l'Union
européenne en fait la majorité des
migrants au Royaume-Uni viennent de
dehors de l'Union Européenne Nigel
Farage il dit ah oui tout ça c'est à
cause de la libre circulation en Europe
en Europe il y a autant de britanniques
dans les autres États membres de l'Union
européenne qu'il y a des ressortissants
européens au Royaume-Uni c'est
équilibré en plus il pe bien plus en
contribution fiscale que qu'il ne coûte
à l'état donc du point de vue du nombre
du point de vue du coût c'est une
bénéfice
pour pour la Grande-Bretagne Royaume-Uni
mais Farage très malin essaie de de
retourner ce débat vous vous parlez de
Nigel Farage le patron de UKIP mais mid
bande le chef du parti travailliste
lui-même veut renforcer le contrôle
migratoire il l'a dit est-ce que c'est
devenu une obsession nationale est-ce
que le Royaume Uni va devenir une
forteresse il y a quand même des
différences des sacré différenceces je
dirais euh ce que le parti travailliste
ve faire
c'est regarder un aspect très
particulier chez nous beaucoup de
prestations sociales sont et de santé
sont financé par la fiscalité pas par
des contributions dans la plupart des
pays il faut d'abord avoir contribuer
avant de de pouvoir bénéficier chez nous
ce n'est pas le cas pour tout pour
toutes les choses chez nous et on dit
seulement que il faudrait que les les
migrants qui arrivent chez nous
attendent et contribu la pour la
fiscalité pendant un certain temps avant
de pouvoir bénéficier autrement tout
tous les migrants de l'Europe risquent
de venir chez nous mais c'est un pas un
problème pas du tout la même chose que
veulent les les racistes ou UKIP ou ce
genre de parti alors la campagne elle
bat son plein chez chez les grands comme
le parti travailliste ou le Parti
conservateur même chez les petits a
votre parti le green parti avec un spot
électoral le votre parti à 1000 paquets
le spot cartonne dans les réseaux
sociaux
regardez
voilà change de tune faut changer la
politique bien sû oui bien sûr on a fait
avec notre spot oui c'est quelque chose
de légère mais avec un message oui c'est
quoi le message principal message
principal oui c'est quoi qui vous différ
par rapport aux grand partis
traditionnel comme le parti travailliste
triste dans cette élection ce que nous
disons c'est que l' stérité c'est c'est
pas le jeu on c'est on doit investir aux
gens on doit investir au futur et c'est
pas seulement question de le déficit de
et cetera on doit investir et c'est le
futur qui compte r cher Corbette sur le
sur le front de l'emploi pourtant ça ça
marche bien en Grande-Bretagne 5,7 % euh
euh de taux de chômage et des jeunes qui
se précipitent vers Londres pour
travailler
euh ça marche bien le problème c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup d'emplois précaires h
pré précair et il y a aussi des grands
problèmes dans nos services publics en
particulier le le service de santé donc
on a on a pu euh augmenter le nombre
mais sur le dos de de créer d'autres
problèmes hm hm et quand on parle
d'austérité nous aussi parti traviste on
est contre l'austérité mais pas en
disant en même temps que le déficit on
sen fout on sait qu' un déficit trop
grand en augmentant les dettes après un
certain temps la plupart de vos recettes
fiscales partent pour pour repayer les
dettes et les taux d'intérêt au lieu de
financer les services publics et
l'investissement donc il faut un
équilibre là il faut diminuer les le
déficit mais pas en coupant tous les
dépens